Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to look at a paper from
three years ago, and not any kind of paper,
but my kind of paper, which is in the intersection
of machine learning, computer graphics, and
physics simulations.
This work zooms in on reproducing reference
motions, but, with a twist, and adds lots
of amazing additional features.
So what does all this mean?
You see, we are given this virtual character,
a reference motion that we wish to teach it,
and here, additionally, we are given a task
that needs to be done.
So, when the reference motion is specified,
we place our AI into a physics simulation
where it tries to reproduce these motions.
That is a good thing because if it would try
to learn to run by itself alone, it would
look something like this.
And if we ask it to mimic the reference motion,
oh yes…much better.
Now that we have built up confidence in this
technique, let’s think bigger, and perform
a backflip.
Uh-oh.
Well, that didn’t quite work.
Why is that?
We just established that we can give it a
reference motion and it can learn it by itself.
Well, this chap failed to learn a backflip
because it explored many motions during training,
most of which resulted in failure.
So it didn’t find a good solution and settled
for a mediocre solution instead.
A proposed technique by the name Reference
State Initialization, RSI in short remedies
this issue by letting the agent explore better
during the training phase.
Got it, so we add this RSI, and now, all is
well, right?
Let’s see.
Ouch.
Not so much!
It appears to fall on the ground and tries
to continue the motion from there.
A+ for effort, little AI, but unfortunately
that’s not what we are looking for.
So what is the issue here?
The issue is that the agent has hit the ground,
and after that, it still tries to score some
additional points by continuing to mimic the
reference motion.
Again, A+ for effort, but this should not
give the agent additional scores.
This method we just described is called early
termination.
Let’s try it!
Now, we add the early termination and RSI
together, and let’s see if this will do
the trick!
…And…yes!
Finally, with these two additions, it can
now perform that sweet sweet backflip, rolls,
and much, much more with flying colors.
So now, the agent has the basics down, and
can even perform explosive, dynamic motions
as well.
So, it is time.
Now hold on to your papers as now comes the
coolest part - we can perform different kinds
of retargeting as well.
What is that?
Well, one kind is retargeting the environment.
This means that we can teach the AI a landing
motion in an idealized case, and then, ask
it to perform the same, but now, off of a
tall ledge.
Or, we can teach it to run, and then drop
it into computer game level and see if it
performs well.
And it really does.
Amazing!
This part is very important because in any
reasonable industry use, these characters
have to perform in a variety of environments
that are different from the training environment.
Two is retargeting not the environment, but
the body type.
We can have different types of characters
learn the same motions.
This is pretty nice for the Atlas robot, which
has a drastically different weight distribution,
and you can also see that the technique is
robust against perturbations.
Yes, this means one of the favorite pastimes
of a computer graphics researcher, which is
throwing boxes at virtual characters and seeing
how well it can take it.
Might as well make sure of the fact that in
a simulated world, we make up all the rules!
This one is doing really well, … oh.
Note that the Atlas robot is indeed different
than the previous model, and these motions
can be retargeted to it, however, this is
also a humanoid.
Can we ask for non-humanoids as well perhaps?
Oh yes!
This technique supports retargeting to T-Rexes,
dragons, lions, you name it.
It can even get used to the gravity of different
virtual planets that we dream up.
Bravo!
So the value proposition of this paper is
just completely out of this world.
Reference State Initialization, Early Termination,
retargeting to different body types, environments,
oh my!
To have digital applications, like computer
games use this would already be amazing, and
just imagine what we could do if we could
deploy these to real-world robots.
And don’t forget, these research works just
keep on improving every year.
The First Law Of Papers says that research
is a process.
Do not look at where we are, look at where
we will be two more papers down the line.
Now, fortunately, we can do that right now!
Why is that?
It is because this paper is from 2018, which
means that followup papers already exist.
What’s more, we even discussed one that
teaches these agents to not only reproduce
these reference motions, but to do those with
style.
And style there meant that the agent is allowed
to make creative deviations from the reference
motion, thus, developing its own way of doing
it.
An amazing improvement.
And I wonder what researchers will come up
with in the near future?
If you have some ideas, let me know in the
comments below.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!